[Música]
vamos ahora las noticias de la economía
con Jorge Hurtado Jorge saludo para
usted qué tal Buenas noches Ángela muy
bien muy bien Quisiera empezar esta
sección de economía sobre los posibles
avances o el posible acuerdo para evitar
el inminente impago de la deuda
estadounidense este es uno de nuestros
titulares del día bueno es que tras una
hora de conversaciones Kevin el
presidente de la cámara de
representantes de Estados Unidos dijo
que las posiciones seguían alejadas
sobre un acuerdo para Elevar el techo de
la deuda de ese país pero afirmó que es
posible llegar a este acuerdo antes de
que acabe la semana y no es tan difícil
llegar a él biden insiste a los
republicanos en considerar formas de
aumentar los ingresos les propone Como
por ejemplo más impuestos a los ricos y
a las empresas para ayudar a pagar
programas de su gobierno del otro lado
los republicanos se niegan a votar para
Elevar el techo de la deuda Más allá del
límite de los 31,3 billones de dólares a
menos de que vayan acepte recortes en el
presupuesto Federal las conversaciones
seguirán estos días escuchemos
creo que fue como dijeron los líderes
fue una reunión mucho más cordial hubo
debates sinceros y Reales sobre las
diferencias que tenemos en toda una
serie de cuestiones pero todo fue
respetuoso y eso fue una buena señal
muy bien Jorge se estrenó en el congreso
el consejero delegado de openhague y la
startup que está detrás del chat de gpt
y esto se parece mucho a nuestro
informativo definitivamente la agenda
concuerda hoy con economía sin duda
alguna hubo muchos temas económicos
bueno como en la mayoría de este tipo de
comparecencias dejaron más preguntas que
respuestas el presidente del poder
judicial del senado el senador
victorving sugirió crear una nueva
agencia dedicada a supervisar el
desarrollo de la Inteligencia artificial
y que tenga alcance internacional Sam
altman se mostró a favor de esta idea y
de que la industria debe ser regulada no
solamente en Estados Unidos sino también
en todo el mundo antman también sugirió
de que se deben considerar requisitos de
las licencias y pruebas para el
desarrollo de estos modelos de
Inteligencia artificial y el punto de
debate fue el uso de la Inteligencia
artificial que pueda interferir en las
futuras elecciones de ese país el hombre
detrás de la tecnología dijo que es un
importante motivo de preocupación
openie cuenta con el respaldo de
Microsoft y aboga por la cooperación
mundial en la materia escuchemos parte
de este debate
es una de mis mayores preocupaciones la
capacidad de estos modelos para
manipular persuadir proporcionar una
especie de desinformación interactiva
uno a uno pero dado que vamos a
enfrentarnos a unas elecciones el
próximo año y estos modelos están
mejorando creo que esta es una área
importante de preocupación creo que hay
muchas políticas que las empresas pueden
adoptar voluntariamente
y esto apenas comienza sin duda alguna
Ángela vamos a hablar de América Latina
y algunos datos de la economía que han
surgido bueno la ralentización de la
economía de nuestra región es un hecho
según un último informe de la ONU del
departamento económico del organismo
mantuvo en por ciento supervisión de
crecimiento para la región este año
Naciones Unidas dejó sin cambios el
cálculo que ya había hecho en enero
pasado para América Latina A diferencia
de otras zonas del mundo y la economía
global donde se registraron algunas
alzas tras el crecimiento del 2022
cuando el pib de la región registró un
3,8% ahora latinoamérica vive un
deterioro económico por la
desaceleración la alta inflación y
también problemas estructurales en cada
país la ONU señala que la subida de los
tipos de intereses en más caro los
préstamos y por esto impacta
negativamente en el gasto de los
consumidores y las inversiones los
gobiernos También tienen muy poco margen
fiscal para empujar la actividad
económica la economía mundial va a
crecer un 2,3% este año según el informe
de la ONU y para el cierre una noticia
bien llamativa en esta región Venezuela
cerró un acuerdo para exportar gas hasta
Europa el acuerdo de explotación se
agrega ahora el mapa energético europeo
en el contexto de la Crisis que hay ahí
la guerra en Ucrania según Pedro
teyechea presidente de petróleos de
Venezuela ese país emitió una licencia a
las operadoras energéticas
internacionales repsol de España y en y
de Italia para explotar y exportar gas
natural a los mercados europeos las
empresas europeos trabajarían en el
proyecto cardón cuarto denominado
también como proyecto Perla en el Golfo
de Venezuela que viene aumentando su
actividad desde el año 2019 Venezuela
quiere llevar al millón de barriles de
crudo producidos para Julio el acuerdo
consiguió los permisos de la oficina de
control de bienes extranjeros de Estados
Unidos pese a las sanciones
internacionales que pesan sobre ese país
se trata del segundo acuerdo en
importancia que logra Nicolás Maduro
después de la extensión de la visa a
Chevron Venezuela es el país con la
octava reserva más grande de gas en el
mundo y mucho de sus megaproyectos no se
lograron ejecutar debido a esta debacle
económica que viven Pues bien Jorge Yo
le agradezco mucho más adelante Habrá
más noticias económicas sin duda nos
vemos en la próxima y vamos ahora al
debate ya regresamos
[Música]